and the tennessee titans are 2-0 and
they are visiting the minnesota vikings
and we are pleased to have here on the
rich eyes and show the
quarterback of those 2-0 tennessee
titans back here ryan tannel how you
been ryan
i'm doing great thanks for having me oh
come on now all good how's life
how's life in the fast lane hey life is
great man it's uh
it's fun to be playing football again
that's for sure okay where have i found
you because i
i can hear people chatting behind you
are those your chatty teammates behind
you ryan
where have i found you right now yeah of
course i mean the uh i'm in the
equipment room you know
uh in a nondescript office my guy uh
matt thompson he does a heck of a job
for us in equipment but he's
allowed me to borrow his desk to uh to
jump on your show
i appreciate that ryan and you thank him
on on my behalf give him an extra chin
strap for me if you don't mind
um no doubt okay well speaking of chin
straps yours is buckled i want to start
with this story that i read
is it true that when you were throwing
uh to uh adam humphries at touchdown
as josh allen hits you and knocks you to
the ground
you before humphreys scored the
touchdown 18-yard touchdown pass you
said the words and won
meaning you were taking the foul and the
bucket was about to be scored did you do
that ryan tannel is that a true story
yeah i mean it was right after he hit me
i'm not sure if pump had just caught it
or was about to catch it or what but um
yeah i did i didn't mutter those words
you said and one because taylor lewan
let everyone know about that called it
badass
that's a true story then yeah
yeah it is it is true you know i was out
there having fun i love competing i love
playing the game
and um you know just just having fun out
there
so you so you confirmed the taylor lawn
story are you are you cool with that
being out there i mean is taylor being a
little too
chatty i mean what do you think ryan
i mean if you spent any time around
taylor you know he's pretty chatty so uh
if he's around nothing's a secret i
don't think i think everyone knows that
but uh okay yeah i mean i i probably
wouldn't have said anything about it but
uh you know it happened i was out there
having fun
you know no harm no foul okay that's
very good because
so do you like the contact is that what
you're saying like you you
you're you're welcoming to taking the
the contact
so what you're saying i prefer not to
have a contact honestly i mean i like
the open j from three
but uh you know if there is a little
contact we can make it happen
okay very good because i guess it is it
is interesting taylor does like talking
um even though he still has not had me
on on his podcast
that he that he co-hosts with compton um
he's got to make that happen now you
look you know what i
i can only offer so much i did as you
know ryan
refused to appear on his podcast busting
with the boys until the bus
that housed the podcast actually had a
motor and it was able to move around
um i have since rescinded that demand
um but it's interesting though that he
would tell the story though because
did that mean he he missed blocking josh
allen is that what that means
uh he was on the other side other side
of the line but he said he uh
for whatever reason his guy got the edge
and he kind of saw it saw it all go down
so
i'm hoping he uh he was finished on his
guy and not worried about what was
happening behind him but
you know he said he heard it i don't
know if he actually heard it or not but
uh
but i definitely said it okay very good
confirmed um it sure looks like you're
you're as comfortable as ever um out
there in this offense
describe for me where how you are
feeling just on that front
ryan for you yeah we still have
a lot of room to improve you know
obviously getting getting two wins
i was huge just coming out of the gates
after after a weird offseason
but you know we're not playing our best
football right now so um
definitely need to improve obviously i'm
settling in still
you know i feel really good about the
guys that we have and um
you know like you said the opportunity
that we have but we need to clean things
up you know we're going on the road
and it's always so even if there's no
fans you know to go on the road and
play a clean football game against a
solid defense i don't think you know
minnesota's probably getting the respect
that they deserve right now
and the fact that they just they play
solid defense they have some good
players
you know harrison smith is making all
types of plays he's all over the field
they play like i said sound defense with
with good technique so
um good challenge for us but excited for
the opportunity to go up there and get
another one yeah i mean
you you know yannick and gakue very well
uh he used to reside in
our division and you're going to be
seeing him later on this weekend and
it's an interesting point that you make
there because i'll be honest with you i
did bury the vikings earlier this week
and
in uh my one like literally i have one
segment per week where i allow myself to
have a hot take
where i just say screw it i'm just gonna
say it the vikings
are my hot take this week so i apologize
if i've if i've stoked anything
um but in gawkway's the the real deal as
you know
what is it i mean you know taking on a
team at owen two going into their house
i mean that is particularly significant
uh what is vrabel telling you about this
sort of stuff where he doesn't really
have to say anything
right now yeah i mean we understand you
know we see the tape
we i think sometimes the scores don't
really reflect
um you know how they played they had
green bay eight to seven up until a
minute before half gave up a
couple quick strikes to aaron rodgers
with with less than a minute to go so
the game was really tight they were
playing good football and it's just
they're just a couple plays away
and you know we respect that we have a
ton of respect going in there
they're going to be a team with their
back against the wall obviously you know
high expectations well-coached team
with some talent so we expect the team
to come out fighting
and and really give us their best shot
okay do you think has there been any
sort of
uh emphasis on because points are up all
over the place like the first two weeks
have been insane
uh has there been any sort of emphasis
on on on holding that you think has been
removed
i mean are you sensing any different way
that the game is being officiated
ryan so far through the first two weeks
you know i gotta
i got a question about that after after
the first week from one of our local
guys and you know i told him we're
coached to play within the rules you
know coach brabel does a great job of
of explaining the rules to us and and
what the refs are seeing and how they're
calling it
and uh you know teaching us to play with
with proper technique because the last
thing we want to do
especially in our type of offense is get
behind the change so
um you know we're not we're not changing
the way that we're going to play we're
going to go out and try to play clean
games
within the rules and uh you know let the
refs do their job all right if you could
wave a wand if you're commissioner
tannehill what what rule would you
change in the nfl
which one would you change which one do
you have like a big pet peeve like that
what do you think oh
come on there's got to be one you're
watching film you're like come on no
i've never i've never actually
i've never actually thought about this
there you go um see that's what i do i
make i
ask thought-provoking questions ryan
that's what i do when when you come here
no i think uh
i think you know some some uh some
defenders are gonna hate me
for this and because i'm a quarterback
of course i'm going to uh to mention the
quarterback rule
that uh you know once you leave the
pocket that you can uh
can take out take out their knees once
you're outside the pocket
and if you're still in a passing um you
know demeanor
okay passing demeanor also i like it
here's the uh here's the other one
okay horse collar within the pocket not
a fan of that one either
horse collar is legal if you're within
the pocket
so you you can be taken down by the
horse collar if you're between your
tackles
so that's what you're saying you have a
big drama unfortunately unfortunately
that that is the rule
okay now here can i give you my pet
peeve i honestly didn't bring this up so
i could bring up mine but um it's
curious i'm curious
since i'm asking a bona fide uh big time
uh professional quarterback here who's
on a hot streak for sure
um that i can't stand that if the ball
is fumbled into and out of the end zone
that the defense gets it
that drives me insane that if you
fumbled it on the half inch yard line
you get to keep it but because
it it is into the end zone about six
inches further up the field you lose it
that drives me nuts yeah that is crazy
and it's coming it's crushing to an
offense you know you see
you see it happen several times every
year guys reaching for the goal line and
end up losing it through the back
uh and it just totally crushes you so
yeah i wouldn't mind seeing that change
okay see that's what i'm saying that's
part of the reason why i'm
i'm i feel like i have a kinship with
you ryan so
um are you gonna watch are you gonna
watch tonight's game
do you watch tonight's game yes or no
yeah i'll probably watch a little bit of
it i never really
i go to bed early man i'm an old man so
i don't never make it to the end of
those things but
i'll definitely flip that thing on for
for a few minutes and see what's going
on
okay uh two things leap to mind uh how
do you watch dolphins games when you see
them
if you ever get a chance do you have any
any
sort of just like watching the other
games come on now come on
really no i mean i know that uh that's
pc but that's that's the truth and i uh
i don't don't feel one way don't root
against them or anything like that you
know i
i enjoyed my time there learned a lot
from from all my experiences there and
uh
you know just another team now by the
way i appreciate you not using the
phrase you've turned the page with me
on that answer i greatly appreciate that
i really really do i'll give you all the
other uh
i'll say that i've turned the page and
all that but no it just
it's just interesting to me that what
has happened
to you since you've been to tennessee
and i'm wondering do you deep down think
that there was no chance based on
circumstances that could have happened
in your old spot
at all ryan no i mean i don't know
you know obviously everything um you
know has a lot of variables and
circumstance and
surroundings make a big difference but
uh you know i don't really go back and
think about that too much
is that because you've turned the page
is that why
you want me to say it don't you you know
what i kind of
you know if you're if if you're not
going to sit here and denigrate your old
team which is not the reason why i'm
asking
or or or yeah go ahead and say it just
go ahead and say it
just go ahead and say it you know what
rich i've turned the page here you go
very good ryan
hill's turn the page now then
what do you mean you're an old man uh
what time do you go to sleep
at night what are you talking about he's
like 9 15 9 30.
out lights out done yeah
yeah lights out bites out and i uh i'm
big on recovery
and you know sleep is is the most
important factor in recovery so
okay call me old call me a grandpa but
sleep is important to me all right
so do you binge watch anything do you
watch anything
uh it's tough to binge when you go to
bed sorry honestly
my wife uh will like to give one episode
of something in at night and uh
what is that you know it gets past eight
o'clock and i'm telling her hey hey
uh we gotta go what is it what are you
watching
what are you in oh i'm ashamed i'm
ashamed to admit this right now but uh
right now we're watching love island
australia
come on real classic
how are you able to turn it off i mean
love island australia
that's what that's that's what you're
watching um
and uh i mean sometimes it's nice to
just have a mindless you know
power just to not think about anything
look at some nonsense and
uh and clear the head a little bit okay
yeah it's
very good and so then then you turn the
page and you go to sleep that's how you
that's basically what you're doing no
doubt on to the next
on to the next did did uh did i did you
just reveal anything or do
do your teammates know that's that's
what you're binge watching while you're
then uh taking the hits from josh allen
saying and one and getting your
teammates to call you a badass
is that is this review i don't go around
announcing it i know uh
i don't go around and knock i know some
of the guys some of the guys know but uh
you know before this we were on snowfall
which i feel like has a little bit more
respect
okay but also a good show i recommend
okay
but um yeah we like to switch it up
serious not serious
okay whatever whatever we're into it's
working for you
ryan thank you for catching up with me
and let's do this
again down the road like i said i know
you don't do this too often so i
appreciate you uh
accepting my uh invitation and coming on
you're welcome here anytime and you tell
you tell lawn uh and by the way the
number of times that i i don't mention
compton as a co-host
is on purpose because it really pisses
him off so
you tell the wanna sit on the show i
don't think he's ever
been on the show he's not right no
no i'm saying his own show
[Laughter]
it is the tale of the one show with the
boys
the singular exactly you take care of
yourself ryan we'll chat soon
all right thanks for asking that's right
who's gonna watch only the first half of
tonight's action and not think about the
dolphins at all
and then go to sleep right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here